[Music]
hey you guys
here we are and it's tuesday yeah
yeah yeah whatever that means it means
it's tuesday
okay i'm sleeping
we were watching this [ __ ] last night
and
it's a good movie but i didn't like it
that's the only way i can describe
you still like mid-summer better like
mid-summer a lot better
i like mid-summer too like i think
mid-summer is also brilliant but i
i tend to like this one better this
one's got a lot of good
this one's like all tone and mood [ __ ]
happens in it
but it's mostly towards the end and it's
kind of like a puzzle
and they're telling they're asking you
to solve this puzzle backwards which i
don't like that [ __ ]
you they're not giving you enough
information to work with and then when
it's over you kind of maybe understand
it but it's
too late because dumbass like myself has
forgotten half the [ __ ] that happened in
the first half so i'm like
yeah no i mean i well no because the
first time i saw it
i mean i figured out what was going on
first time i saw it i fell asleep
remember well i know you did
yeah we saw in the theater yeah um so
the first time
it's just one that you have to pay
attention to and like i said it's a
movie that
i'm always kind of one of those people
it's like unless it's just some like
mindless popcorn flick if you're gonna
watch a movie watch the [ __ ] movie
like pay attention
if you don't pay attention to it then
don't watch it you know what i'm saying
if you pay attention to it then you'll
figure out what's going on because
everything in there
is either foreshadowed or it's something
you know it's uh they talk about it like
in conversations and stuff
but like i said you just have to
remember things you know
the first half is very slow all right
to me there not much is happening and
you're like why the hell am i watching
this
it was amusing when that girl's head got
knocked off and the movie theater jenny
would attest to it
it surprised me that that happened i
didn't see that coming her head got
knocked off and i [ __ ] laughed
and then you're so bad people got mad
well it was so
you're such an edge lord
[Laughter]
see that's how she's coming i didn't
like the little girl
and and when it happened i didn't expect
it so my only reaction was to like
i kind of laughed at a surprise and then
they showed the head with all the
[ __ ]
flies on it and i was like yeah it's
pretty cool but then
i i started getting relaxed and i fell
asleep right after that
all right yeah and i woke up around the
time when that
woman went crawling through the sky and
went
and out the door i heard you guys it was
you and who was that you and shauna yeah
me and sean
and that woke me up and i was looking to
see her crawling through this guy i was
like yeah that's pretty cool
and then i saw the very end where they
had the damn ceremony at the end
and i was like i mean spoilers in case
it's creepy [ __ ]
yeah that's some creepy [ __ ] but i
missed all the good parts
yeah you did the first time first time i
missed all the good parts
the second time i go back and it was
still slow
it is better there's a lot of stuff
going on
that like i said you really have to be
paying attention and that's why i really
wanted to
and i'm like zach is really excited that
i'm finally talking about this
because um oh and by the way thank you
esther because esther sent us
mid-summer and hereditary on blu-ray
like for tom's birthday yeah
and i had been wanting to watch this a
second time because we saw it in the
theater that was the last time i saw it
and then i was like man that movie was
amazing i don't think i ever want to
watch it ever again because it made me
just feel so
weird and i was just kind of like you
know what i mean
so i was like i don't know if i want to
see that again after she was saying that
i started to get interested in seeing it
again
and so like what i did was i didn't
watch the movie itself i was
like watching all these um like analysis
videos about it because i was like well
this is kind of like watching it again
except i don't have to like watch it
again
but then finally i was kind of like look
i gotta watch it again like we got
like we got it esther sent it to us and
so last night he was like you want to
watch hereditary and i cut
my stomach kind of went like that and i
was like yeah okay let's watch it
and then it was it was not as
stressful this time because even though
it's been three years since i've seen it
the real um creepy [ __ ] that
really like bothered me um
those images stayed in my brain that
whole entire time
so so i knew what i was gonna see so
it's still like creepy but it wasn't
you know when you see it the first time
you're not you don't know what to expect
you know what i mean so some of the [ __ ]
that happens is like the
the imagery is really unsettling so
since i still remembered the [ __ ]
all these years later um it didn't
stress me out as much but it's still
i liked watching it a second time this
is definitely one if you liked it the
first time
really really watch it a second time
because there is a lot
a lot of like foreshadowing and
symbolism and all kind of [ __ ] that's
going on
and you don't necessarily notice it the
first time that you watch it
and it will give you like a real
appreciation
of how [ __ ] well put together
this [ __ ] movie is and especially
considering this is ari astr's first
feature-length film he had made a couple
short films prior to this
but this was his first one and the fact
that
it's this accomplished and like
everything relates to everything else
and every like every single shot
it's very kubricky and you kind of said
that too in the sense that every single
shot
means something like the way it's framed
and like everything it's just like
it's really like a work of genius i
think yeah i don't
i don't doubt you know i mean i'm not
gonna say that it's it's a bad movie
no it's it's a great movie i just didn't
really like it
yeah and that's fair enough a lot a lot
of things
you know a lot of movie is you know
kind of like your personal tastes and
what you're experiencing when you see it
i just i thought it was too slow um
but it did have a lot of really good
things going for it
it had a really good score the way it
was shot
you know what i mean uh shot composition
and edit was really good
um acting was really good in it i mean
the acting is amazing and like i think
some somebody was saying earlier like
why
tony call it didn't get an oscar nom for
this i really have no idea
stuff interesting stuff happens in it
but
a lot of it's at the end and uh
i could have taken more of it you know
um
it was kind of front loaded with kind of
slow
build up stuff and i don't need that
much
build up you know some people do but i
didn't to me it really didn't get
interesting until the little girl's head
got knocked off and then the seances
that's when it started to get kind of
interesting but it
seemed like it took an hour to get to
that
it probably didn't but the thing about
it that seemed like it took
is that and i think i appreciated this
more the second time although i loved it
the first time
i think i appreciated more the second
time because i knew
what was coming and i knew what the
whole uh conceit of it was
i really thought so the second time i
watched it it was in a way
even though like the imagery wasn't as
upsetting because i remembered it from
last time
but it was in a way it was even more
dread inducing because i knew
exactly what was happening with uh the
cult
and coming to the realization
that the the cult and the grandmother
who's dead has been
essentially controlling this family's
entire lives
and they're not aware of it and like
every it's almost it's like rosemary's
baby in the sense that like
everybody's in on it you know what i'm
saying and it's like and everything they
do
is manipulated and they're not aware of
like they're trying to break out of this
curse or whatever um you know this this
cycle
and they can't do it because no matter
what they do
the cult is there and they are like
manipulating things
to the end that they want yeah and so
and and the second time you watch it you
really pick that up a lot more than the
first time
yeah i wasn't aware of any kind of cult
yeah it wasn't until she had to tell me
this kind of stuff
i'm like who is this why what it was
look at that old man that you you know
like
what do you say what is going on here we
hate to go
yeah i'm like that guy what the [ __ ] is
going on here who's this old lady
you know who's that he's like i don't
mean to laugh at you but you do sound
just like that old man in jurassic park
all those years ago that i still i'm
sure that dude is dead by now because
she was like [ __ ] 100.
some of these artistic movies they don't
really just come out and say
anything you have to figure it out for
yourself although this one does
i think it's really weird because it's
so subtle it goes right over my head not
really
you just have to listen to their
conversations
and like i said i think that that's kind
of good because the first time you watch
it
um you know you listen to the
conversations and stuff but it doesn't
really come together until the end
but then the second time you watch it
knowing what you know
about the end and about the cult and
about what they've been trying to do the
whole time actually even before
charlie the little girl was born or even
before uh peter the son was born
uh you know the grandmother's been
trying to do this [ __ ] for like a
generation or two
right and has been failing and so this
cult has been manipulating this family
and they essentially have no control
over their actions and so
knowing that going in which i did the
second time
every single conversation every single
everything
um it just kind of ties into the whole
bigger narrative like i say
everything is interrelated like i said
it's almost like it's like rosemary's
baby but like
on a bigger scale because everything
you're like paranoid everybody is in on
the [ __ ]
rosemary's baby though telegraphed
itself everything was very obvious
yeah you know this one is not it's a lot
more subtle
you have to pay close attention and
i'm not the kind of guy that really pays
close attention to what's going on that
much in these movies if
my mind is if it's not something that's
really pulled me in early
my mind will start wandering and i'll
start thinking about other things and
you know wondering how long the movie's
gonna take
that kind of stuff it's just and it's
just
like i said i got that that five ten
minute rule if i'm not really sucked
into the story very early on and i
and if i'm then i'm never really going
to get into it
and a lot of it has to do with
disorientation if the story disorients
me
early on i just kind of reject it start
tuning it out
i think that's what happens well i think
i mean
i kind of lose interest in it well
coming from my point of view like i said
maybe it's more because
i'm a writer and i'm kind of more into
this kind of stuff i
i interpreted it i interpret it as poor
writing
not genius but well i can't follow story
because it's poorly written
because there's a lot of movies that are
like that a lot of [ __ ] ton
shitty movies are just they're so poorly
written you can't follow the story
so sometimes a good movie will fool me
when i first saw this in the theater i
just thought it was poorly written i
didn't think there was anything to it so
i fell asleep in it
it's not poorly written though no it's
actually it's actually really
it's actually brilliantly written but
you know but if you're not going to pay
attention to it then it might as well be
right right right so i didn't get pulled
into it but that's not the movie's fault
though
kind it is i think well not really it's
not for a general audience
no but i mean they never said that it
was right right
yeah okay never mind
well i i think you kind of come at
things where it's like you think
everything should be for a general
audience
but i don't think everything should be
for a general audience people should
just make the [ __ ] they want to make
yeah like if you not for a general
audience there's some people
well yeah i know but like i said you
know the fact that this got that ari
astra made this
it's like you know for me and people
like me that would like it i don't care
if other people don't like it or not i
thought it was amazing
and you know if other people don't like
it that's fine it's like you know
and horror is subjective too because a
lot of people like i said i saw this
movie and it's just like it really
really bothered me and like horror
movies don't
usually bother i love horror movies but
they don't usually scare me scaring me
this one really i don't know
i guess i don't know it just gave me
really really bad anxiety
and like i had nightmares about it and
stuff like that which never happens
and i was like [ __ ] up about it but i
was also like happy about it because i
was kind of like man that really did
what it
said it was gonna do so you know a good
job there and i hadn't seen a movie in a
long time that had done that like not
really since i was a kid
that made me feel like that but then
again
that's what made me not want to watch it
a second time because it made me feel so
bad the first time
because it's like it's not even so much
i don't know there's just so much in
this
that's so unsettling
i don't even know if it was so much
like the the creeping dread and like
paranoia of being
watched and like not having any control
over
anything in your life but not being
aware of that
and as i said it's like really but i
mean a lot of the imagery in it is
really creepy yeah like the girl's head
and [ __ ] like that that's like [ __ ]
that was [ __ ] up and the way that they
uh edited that
was [ __ ] amazing because everyone was
like what the [ __ ] you know what i mean
because it just like
here it is they just threw it right in
your face which they hardly ever show
[ __ ] up like dead decapitated kids
in [ __ ] movies right well she was
thirteen i think when she yeah thirteen
well it's still a kid
yeah uh you know so they so then they
just kind of like threw it in your face
after they didn't really there wasn't
like a lot of creepy imagery going up to
that
but it's just like i thought the
atmosphere of dread was like really well
done
i was watching the um the what you call
it the documentary about the making of
it and what i didn't realize
was that the outside of the gram's house
that was a real house it was in utah but
the insides much like stanley kubrick
uh the inside of the house was entirely
built on sets
and they did that so they could pull
walls out
and get like particular uh angles and
[ __ ]
because one of the things one of the
visual motifs
like i said was annie you know she's the
artist and she makes all these
miniatures and stuff
and that's kind of her way of dealing
with the trauma
uh you know of her past life like her
relationship with her mom like her dad
and her brother
dying like killing themselves and [ __ ]
like that and uh
the possibility that she might be
carrying that she might be mentally ill
as well
and that's kind of her way of distancing
herself by making everything small like
she has control over it
but then the fact that he's taking it
back one level
to a macro level where it's like now
when you're seeing the actual movie
he shoots everything as though he's
shooting it in a dollhouse
because he's making it seem like there's
a much larger force
outside of these people that's
controlling their actions and they're
not aware
of it and that's you know i mean so like
just the fact that he did that and that
he built the whole entire [ __ ] house
on a sound stage just so he could
explore that visual motif it's like
that's [ __ ] amazing
and the fact that this movie only costs
10 million dollars to make
is also quite amazing and it made 80
million
so this is actually like a24s as far as
i know it's their highest grossing
uh movie i mean you gotta even if you
don't love every single a24 movie
everything they put out is interesting
yeah it's kind of like an art house
movies
yeah and you know even like i said i
haven't loved every single one but most
of the 824 ones i've seen are good like
st
mod was [ __ ] great i reviewed that
not too long ago um
you know mid-summer was great the
lighthouse was great although that's
very
that's weird too that was a weird it was
awareness movie
i think i think studios like this though
are going to be the way the future
anyway
but that's good i mean that's good for
me because they're because
they're more creative than a mainstream
um
studio they're taking risks that other
studios wouldn't take
right i didn't like this one i liked
mid-summer a lot more
i definitely want to watch mid-summer
again maybe
it's a little it's a linear story
although mid-summer you could
when we first saw midsummer in the
theater i thought you would think that
was
way slower than hereditary because i
thought it was slower than hereditary
um but i don't mind i don't mind stuff
being slow that's not a criticism to me
it was a lot
more understandable because i'm a
patient person yeah you know what i mean
to me it was a lot more
understandable it was a lot more uh
exciting i think
like um you said that this one had like
feelings of dread and it was it was
emotionally evocative to you
to me it didn't evoke any emotion yeah
well some people have that but like i
said horror is subjective yeah
this one maybe it's because you know the
accident where charlie gets killed
that was like based on a real accident
that happened in georgia in 2004.
okay um so somebody did actually it
wasn't a kid but it was a guy and he did
actually get killed he was a passenger
in a car and he was drunk and he hung
his head out the window
um and that so and also maybe it's
because
i have a younger sister and so maybe
i thought to myself what would have hap
what would have happened if like when i
was a teenager and i was driving my
sister somewhere
because she's about the same yeah she's
you know seven years younger than me
and what if that had happened and like
just and it's like that's horrifying
enough like even thinking about that
but then his [ __ ] reaction to it
was like i i loved that sequence as
horrible as horrific as it was
where like after the accident he's just
like sitting there and he kind of looks
in the river and he's like no like he
doesn't want to look like he can't
believe it
and then like he just goes home yeah
with the headless body in the back
because he doesn't know what else to do
it's like he's in total shock and then
he just like and then they kind of cut
to him just like laying in bed with his
eyes open and then you just hear
tony call it like screaming outside i
was like can you imagine
finding your headless daughter in the
back seat of a car
oh my god and i was just kind of like so
that whole thing and like i said maybe
it's because i have a younger sister
myself
i have two younger brothers also and
it's like i thought and i could think
i could put myself into his shoes like
what like you would never
you could never fix that you could never
get over that you could never
holy [ __ ] and then like to have your mom
blame you
even though it was an accident really um
you know
because she blamed him as well for it
and then later her saying like the [ __ ]
to him like it's like i didn't want to
be your mother and i tried to abort you
and all this other kind of [ __ ]
that's like [ __ ] horrifying so i
think that
it depends on your family situation too
maybe like because i think that
as i said horror is kind of subjective
so what scares one person doesn't get a
scary
did nothing for me i didn't even really
notice that yeah
funny well like i said that's that's why
because everybody has different
triggers everybody has different things
that bother them everybody has different
you know and i have certain things in
movies that pretty much always creep me
out and i'm not
entirely sure why i am really really
super creeped out in movies by
doppelganger kind of [ __ ] and so that's
why like david lynch kind of stuff like
whether it's one person's over here and
they're in the same place at the same
time and [ __ ] like that
that really really bothers me and that
and that scene from uh
that scene from lake mungo like where
like where she has the video and like
she sees herself like all the
it's like that [ __ ] freaks me out and
i don't really know why like i've tried
to kind of
i've tried to kind of figure out why
that is like why i'm so upset by
doppelgangers in movies but that's like
one of the things that creeps me out the
most
and i don't know why the only scene that
was like that that weirded me out was
the one from the tenant
when he was looking back yeah see that
really bothers me
and then he looks and he sees himself in
the window and there was a scene like
that in 1408 too like john cusack
looking out the window and seeing
himself like in the thing that like
that every time that happens in a movie
i'm just like
i think that had a lot to do with how
old i was at the time that i saw it
too like maybe because i've seen stuff
similar to that since then and recently
and and it doesn't do that i mean it
depends on how it's done
too because i mean i've seen i've seen
it done in movies where
i was just kind of like okay whatever
but if it's in a good movie
and it has like some context behind it
yeah then it'll really bother me and
like and i'm glad you brought up the
tenant because yeah that that scene in
the tenant like really freaked me out
other than this and that and the scene
where he finds that [ __ ] tooth and
the hole in the wall
yeah that whole movie was which was a
trip although
um one one person would recommend to see
it in the comments section they were
like boy that was a waste of my time you
know so i
think has to do with how old you are
when you see it in the context of the
time in which you see it
because there was nothing like that back
in the 80s it was yeah the movie from
the 80s and as i said it's
you know it's kind of slow and you're
not really sure what the hell is going
on but it sure was [ __ ] weird
um but that's another story that's why i
try i try not to get on people's case
too much about
you know it if somebody like if i you
know like i saw hereditary i loved
hereditary it freaked me the [ __ ] out
i was really anxious about seeing it
again although i really wanted to
i watched a bunch of like analysis
videos against i got into it just like i
got into the shining man like with all
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was going on elements to it it
does the shining is a lot better i mean
yeah well they're two kind of they're
different movies like i said this one's
almost kind of more like a kubricky
intake rosemary's baby in some way kind
of like yeah
yeah yeah it's like like it's as if
kubrick was doing rosemary
or doing something like that like that
you know what i mean so
uh so i just felt like i was swimming
through most of it like i didn't have
enough information to to really follow
the story
and it was probably sneaking me
information into the side it was
but that's and like i said it wasn't
really sneaky because like a lot of it
was just
in conversations and stuff yeah but then
you're asking me to remember certain
facts from a conversation
and then relating it to something else
that happens later and i don't
tend not to do that not especially not
if it's not something that has to do
with
supernatural stuff you know i'm kind of
taking each conversation as its own
thing
it just didn't really come across as it
came across as slow
and not linear and kind of nonsensical
at the end certain things were kind of
made sense
but it to me it seemed like much to do
about nothing
um it wasn't scary to me there was a
couple of um
effects that they used in the scenes
that i thought were kind of
cool looking like the woman crawling
through the sky
they were crawling through the air in
the room the best thing about that was
that there was no sound
yeah the ghost she saw the ghost of her
mom in there that was a pretty good
effect
yeah i liked that though dude standing
there grinning in the darkness
that was also super creepy and then the
little uh the mannequin with the weird
human head on it
but that was it it doesn't really wasn't
worth watching the movie to see those
things
you know what i mean and the story what
to me wasn't very scary
and um i didn't really relate to any of
the characters i
i didn't find any of the character was
likable
i think that might had something to do
with it too i didn't like the little
girl i didn't like the mom
i didn't like the dad well i didn't like
the guy i didn't like the boy
i didn't like any of those people so i
think i didn't really care what happened
to him
that might have been what it was but
like i said that's
you know that's you though yeah i mean
you know
i really dug this movie yeah and you
know it's it's to taste
yeah i mean it's actually probably it's
probably my favorite uh horror movie of
the 21st century so far
yeah just because i'm not condemning
your opinion on it don't
look at it that way i'm just it seems
like you kind of like
well because well offense to it or
something well no because sometimes
well sometimes though like when i talk
about like if i like a movie and i kind
of like talk about it you kind of like
just [ __ ] on it like
no like well it's not for a general
audience
and you just kind of sound like that
like all condescending stuff no
like
kind of like the other way around you're
a writer and you're real smart and
you're patient you're looking into stuff
the general audience really uh isn't
isn't there to
like have to well right but it's working
like i said
i'll be a detective all movies aren't
made for them it's like it's not my
fault if you're a dumbass and you can't
follow stories
like you know what i mean um you know
that's not the movie's fault either it's
like you know
because everything all the information
that you needed was in there
and you know and it wasn't a hidden it
wasn't like
it wasn't like a david lynch situation
where you actually had to kind of
interpret everything this wasn't like
that like all the information was there
um you just had to listen everyone's
conversations relate things to other
things that people had said earlier
just like you would do if you're reading
a novel or anything like that it's not
like anything unusual
right you know it wasn't i didn't think
you necessarily had to figure anything
out
it's like it it unrolled kind of the
information
slowly because like i said the first
time i went to see it i
didn't want to know like i didn't watch
the trailer and nothing i just because i
like going into horror not knowing
anything about it
i like the experience of just letting it
come at me and like me like figure out
what's going on in it you know i don't
have to know what kind of movie is going
to be ahead of time i don't need to know
that
i'm the same with books and everything
like that i don't read the i don't read
the [ __ ] the back i don't do anything
you weren't there with me watching that
thing
all right and and i didn't have you
there to explain to me what what was
going on i would have gotten halfway
through that and not understood it
yeah all right so just but like i said
it's true
i i didn't think it was like all that
hard to figure out yeah
it's kind of hard to figure out i didn't
think it was that i mean
it's very subtle the way certain with
the way the story is told it's told
in kind of an unconventional way it's
not the way
that a movie usually communicates it's
just you know
more like the shining the shining is
real vague about what the hell's going
on too
but see that's what i think it kind of
helps you understand what's happening
yeah but i mean we've kind of talked
about this before that was the thing
that i liked about the shining and
actually
i thought that was what you liked about
the shining too is that i read the book
though
well yeah so did i but honestly i think
i saw the movie before i read the book
yeah i saw the movie before
to be honest i didn't understand it oh i
did i didn't really understand it but um
you know when i was a kid that scared me
but i didn't know yeah it scared the
crap out of me but i didn't really
understand what
was i didn't really understand what was
going on i knew ghosts had something to
do with it
i liked that kubrick chose not to
explain things like i said a lot of
times
and this is you know i've brought this
up a lot
i don't like horror that explains too
much because if you explain too much
it's not scary anymore
it's not scary anymore unknown stuff is
scarier than known stuff
don't explain everything let it's like
let people come to their own conclusions
i think is better
i think it's a more satisfying
experience watching a story that
is not just spoon fed to you you know
what i mean i don't really like movies
that
just explain everything or give you all
the information and like just say
oh well this happened because of this
you know and you know and
i would have succeeded if it wasn't for
you meddling kids type of thing where
like that
you're like a bond thing where the
villain describes this big elaborate
plot like at the end i don't like that
it's like really i find that really um
insulting like a condescending like i'm
too dumb to figure it out on my own
so i don't really like movies that
explain things
explain over explain themselves it's
like you can err on the wrong side of
that too
like where it's you're you're refraining
from explaining so much that like no one
knows what the [ __ ] you're talking about
but i've very very rarely seen that
happen
and honestly sometimes when you leave
things ambiguous
in certain ways that's good because then
people can bring their own [ __ ] to it
and it's more like a personal experience
you know what i'm saying so i don't know
but that said i didn't think this movie
was uh was
ambiguous really i mean it explained
itself pretty well
um you didn't know what was going on
as it was unfolding but by the end
if you'd paid attention to all the [ __ ]
that was going on prior
then it was pretty clear what was going
on
the only thing i didn't catch the first
time that i
that i caught this time was that i
didn't realize and like i said spoiler
alert too late now probably
but um i didn't realize that charlie
was housing the demon the whole time
the demon was in there the whole time
that's why she was like acting so weird
and [ __ ]
yeah i never would have got that i only
i only figured that out like um
[Music]
like the second time i watched it i was
just kind of like oh okay
because i thought that because i was
like why didn't the demon go in her
before but i was like no the demon went
in her like when she was born
pretty much yeah well they said that at
the end the priestess said that they got
rid of the
[ __ ] up female body and put you in the
mail yeah you deserve to be in type of
deal well because the only reason that
they put the demon in charlie
was because um when peter was born the
older kid
um annie was not speaking to her mother
and kept peter away from her
they wanted peter yeah actually they at
first wanted
uh her brother like annie's brother but
she says in the grief group he
committed suicide when he was 16 because
he was i think we lost connection
it says reconnection successful is it
going are we back again we'll see
it looks like we had a little hiccup
yeah
i get the commercial i think we got
connections back is it
maybe we'll see i gotta i mean nothing
crashed or anything
all right yeah sorry about that had a
little had a little hiccup
but uh storming out here yeah we got it
there's there's a storm outside
there's always a storm outside this time
of year yeah yeah this time of day too
but yeah so they just basically put them
in there as a placeholder until they
could
um until they could manipulate
everything to a point where
um they could get at peter and put the
demon in him because that's
who what they were supposed to be doing
so everything that happens in the movie
is engineered by the cult
is engineered by the demon like with the
demon's help you know what i mean like
even the accident that kills charlie
if you look like when he first passes uh
the utility pole that she busts her head
off on
uh there's the payment symbol is on
there like when he passes it
so and when he comes back like the
reason that he swerves there's a deer in
the road so obviously the cult people
put it there so he would swerve so they
engineered everything
to see i i didn't even catch that yeah
and so everything was engineered
to make peter vulnerable and to get rid
of his soul
like all this trauma all this kind of
[ __ ] not only to get rid of charlie so
payman could have
like the bet the male body that he
wanted but also
um you know so so that the whole family
would fragment
and he would be left like the only one
and he'd be so [ __ ] up that he'd be
vulnerable to demon possession
essentially
so that's kind of like what so everybody
was in on it
and i think i've seen some theories too
that even the girl at the party that
made peter go into the room with the
bong or whatever
that maybe even she was in the cult or
at least
was influenced by the call because they
had a demon on their side right too so
they could
manipulate events so pretty much
everything in this is made
so they were faded from the beginning
for this to happen no matter what they
did
like so annie tried to fight against it
but her fighting against it ironically
put her like right back into the
clutches of the cult without her
realizing it because she didn't really
know
about it you know what i'm saying like
the whole [ __ ] with that woman that
coming across her at the grief group and
said hello i need to go to the seance
and
here have this piece of paper that has
this thing on it so you can talk to your
daughter again which was a demon
invocation
obviously that's what that was they were
just like trying to get her to
vulnerable to it so she would like say
this say the [ __ ]
and bring the uh bring the demon out so
it could get into peter
so it's like every single thing in this
was calculated
and watching it a second time i was just
it's like every single time like
somebody said someone was like oh
[ __ ] oh yeah cause it's like
knowing it the second
time it's like you see all the little
clues even all the [ __ ]
like with peter in the classrooms every
single classroom discussion that they're
having
is something to do with what's going on
like they talk about
oedipus they talk about like all this uh
i think it's like a sophocles play
and he talks about like all these things
about fate you know what i mean where
you know you're prophesied to do
something and like no matter what you do
you can't get out of it because it's not
in your control it's like under the
god's control or whatever
um so so everything in this like has a
meaning like that
which i thought was like super super
cool so like i said that's really the
reason i love
love love like [ __ ] movies like that
this you guys have heard me talk about
like [ __ ] mulholland drive right
um which is kind of like a similar kind
of thing in the sense that it's sort of
like a puzzle or they're
it needs to be kind of interpreted more
than this movie i think this movie's
pretty straightforward
generally but i love stuff like that
you know what i mean yeah what's
happening
me watching it i didn't get all that
detail if i didn't have jenny with me i
wouldn't have understood any of it i
don't think
no i was like what the hell is this
who's this what's going on and i didn't
really notice any of the uh
connections i didn't notice the
connections i didn't notice the demons
going in and out of people's bodies i
didn't see any demons i just saw some
lights
it's light well that's well that was the
representation yeah
was that weird blue light yeah see that
they kept seeing
how to put horns on it and the [ __ ]
tail and the pitchfork and [ __ ] let you
know yeah that's a demon
because to me it just [ __ ] wave of
light
and just a little uh pixie thing went in
there
it's just it's just a lot of it was just
like i don't know it it didn't
communicate very well to me
that's not my it wasn't my style but you
know you liked it
yeah it's a well-made movie so you know
yeah and like i said
i don't like stuff that's like really
really obvious yeah i thought
that [ __ ] would be obvious to me and
there'd be a comedy in it and stuff like
that too
probably that's that then i'd understand
it a lot more and then you'd have some
dude commenting on it
you know what i mean in the in the story
some guy saying
i know there's a demon in here somewhere
do you see him that kind of stuff you
know
they have to be some kind of somebody to
explain what the hell's going on
another another shot i didn't notice too
like the first time i watched it but i
noticed this the second time
was that when they show like the outside
of the house like right toward the end
like right before peter uh goes and
becomes payment or whatever
it's like outside of the house is all
the little naked cult numbers
yeah down in the yard and it's like i
didn't notice it the first time but the
second time i'm like oh [ __ ]
look they're like all around like
they're closing in like they were all
around them i couldn't even see it when
she
when she said something about it and i
was watching to see trees
i was no there was like there was a
little people that was like naked people
i don't know
all around i couldn't see it yeah they
were that was all the cult members they
were like closing in like getting ready
for the ceremony
so it's just kind of like it's i love
the way they did too
um a lot of the shots that they had
earlier in the film
where they would kind of linger like on
a dark corner and like for a second
you'd think like is there something in
there like what
and that because they were priming you
like there wasn't necessarily something
in the shadows every single time but
they were priming you later to like kind
of get you
oh there's nothing there but then later
on they did put some [ __ ] in there
so i think that was like pretty genius
also like i think it's funny because the
first time we saw in the theater and i
was like watching another review where
they said like the the kind of infamous
shot where uh
you know peter gets out of bed and his
and tony kala is like up there in the
[ __ ] corner like up by the ceiling
and it's like really dark and some
people depending on what theater you saw
it at or what tv you watched that some
people didn't notice are up there
um i saw her in the theater like you
know our theater was like bright enough
that i actually did see her
but i didn't see her at first i was just
kind of like looking going what's wrong
and i was like oh [ __ ] like she's up
there
and it was that kind of thing so you
know a lot of people didn't see her
until like two or three times
uh later yeah i'm gary i'm guaranteed
people that saw that in the movie
theater watch us on television
didn't even see and didn't even see one
quarter of the [ __ ] that you saw well
yeah they probably didn't no and they
didn't even because i pay attention and
they didn't understand any of that [ __ ]
because i paid attention yeah like i
said it's not my fault people are dumb
asses it's really not
that's not my problem that [ __ ] went all
way above their head
way over there um that was just like we
were watching the lighthouse in that
same studio
i liked the [ __ ] movie i knew they
were [ __ ] with me through the whole
that movie is batshit crazy and i love
it crazy as [ __ ]
i don't know if i'd call it a horror
movie exactly but
[ __ ] was crazy ass movie it was
[ __ ] crazy and then at the end
of the day [ __ ] looks into the
lighthouse into the [ __ ] light of the
lighthouse it goes
and then ants people are going oh then
they [ __ ] watch it
what are they i liked it though i liked
it what are they teaching kids these
days
well like i said you know every movie is
not for everybody obviously
like there's a lot of movies i don't
like either i don't [ __ ] on other people
for like liking particular movies that i
don't particularly like because
everybody's different
yeah but it's like i really don't like i
don't like it when
because one thing i've heard because
like i said i'm a big david lynch fan
and one thing that i've heard from some
uh [ __ ] is that
oh david lynch just makes these movies
and they're just weird
for weird's sake and he's just like
[ __ ] with all of y'all
and then he's kind of like picking on
people like me he's like oh you guys are
finding a meeting where there isn't
any or he's just like pulling stuff out
of his ass and he is absolutely not
pulling stuff out of his yeah
it means something it it does mean
something it's like i don't
it's like look it's like just because
you know yeah
like i said it's not my fault if you're
a dumbass it's like
you know what i'm saying it's like that
doesn't mean i'm not pretending to be
smart just to make you feel bad about
being a dumbass you know what i'm saying
it's like i'm not pretending that i
understand a david lynch movie just to
make you feel stupid
you know not you i'm just like like
saying the general you um
but some people apparently do think that
they're so insecure about their
dumbassery that they will accuse people
of making stuff
up like to seem smarter just to make
them feel bad
i have seen that happen and i'm just
kind of like
nobody's doing that dude
[Laughter]
no david lynch stuff means stuff it does
now sometimes what it means is open to
interpretation meta it's
[ __ ] happening outside the film and it's
the film looking back in on the film
there's all kinds of [ __ ]
well and the thing about it well the
thing about it is that
one he works from a very dream-like
logic perspective but he is absolutely
referring to
other movies too outside of his so it's
not like so weird like he's just
oh you know he's referring to like some
weird obscure [ __ ]
it's like sometimes he's just referring
to other movies or you know the
the context of other movies and if you
don't haven't seen that other movie
then you'll think that he's just like
pulling stuff out of his butt but he's
totally not
yeah you know what i mean yeah so that
that's all it is
yeah but that little scene where the the
uh
the cult members were standing around
outside the house i guarantee you
nine ninety percent of people did not
see that on first viewing but i didn't
see it you have to use it i didn't see
it on the first feeling i saw the second
view i didn't see it when you
even mentioned it i didn't i couldn't
see it because when they show that shot
you kind of net your eyes are naturally
drawn into looking at the sky
well yeah the sky and the tree in the
house and yeah and the house a little
bit
but i didn't see the people there even
although i believe you that they're
there
there was a lot of stuff that was
probably there that you didn't see
if you go through it you probably see
all kinds of little things in there
well yeah um and so and there are videos
70s album cover
you're getting high and you're looking
at the album well there are videos on
youtube like pointing out like
actually i saw one today that said that
one of the cult members was in a certain
scene that i hadn't noticed them in
yeah um but see that's what i like about
that kind of [ __ ] where it's like
they're just like we're not even gonna
i don't even care if like you notice it
or not i'm just putting it there
because sometimes your subconscious
might notice it and it makes you nervous
but you don't know why because you don't
see it like with your conscious mind
and [ __ ] well yeah that's right but well
there's there's like way worse like
filmmakers that you could emulate
just saying but he has his own thing
though
i mean i wouldn't really i mean
hereditary
is sort of it's it's not kubrickian
in the sense that because i feel like
kubrick had
a real um
[Music]
his [ __ ] is very kind of like
emotionally cold or like you know what i
mean he kind of keeps the characters at
arm's length a little bit i don't like
hereditary not so much like that
hereditary was very much
uh you know putting your face into these
people's like
raw emotions you know what i mean like
look at this grief
look at this you know so it was so it
was like a different kind of thing but
he has some similarities in the way that
uh in the style that he shoots things
and
the artifice of it but as i said
um the artifice in this movie
was in service to the theme of the movie
because midsummer didn't really have
that so much
that was kind of more like nature but
also it was like trippy because they
kept seeing like lsd like all the trees
were
swirling and [ __ ] like that like very
subtly in the background
i liked i used man i want to watch that
again too i've said it several times but
i like i liked uh
mid summer better than this one yeah
well some people do
you know what i mean like of the two i
really i loved mid-summer too i thought
that was also a great movie
but i feel like ari astor we'll see what
he does next but
one of the things that he seems very
just from these two movies
one of the things that he seems really
interested in like i said is
fate and if you can avoid it because
it's a really big deal in this one
but another thing that i noticed in
mid-summer was that
you know the mural that he shows like at
the beginning of mid-summer like during
the opening credits even
that mural shows every single thing that
happens
in the movie so again leading everybody
to believe that the characters
um you know are kind of doomed from the
start this is what's going to happen to
them
and there's nothing that they can do
about it so ari astra seems like really
really into the idea
of a fate that you can't avoid which
i can't what which i dig that because
i've written some kind of stories like
that too
because that's like a really horrifying
prospect to feel like no matter what you
do
um you know you're going to have the
inevitable is going to happen to you
even if you try to avoid it like i said
it's a very oedipus type of thing where
it's like
oh there's like there's there's prophecy
that you're gonna kill your dad and
marry your mom
and he's like oh i better get the [ __ ]
out of here to like not have that happen
but then the fact of him leaving
out of there like made it happen anyway
like when he didn't like mean for it to
so that kind of [ __ ] is like pretty
scary so i think that
you know that seems to be a pet theme
yeah of his
and they're talking about mid-summer i
like mid-summer better too because i was
i was more i'm more familiar with the um
with the topic too
yeah because it you know had all that
folklore stuff it's kind of like it's
kind of like a wicker man
and you know so i kind of
was kind of more familiar with some with
you know neo-paganism and paganism and
[ __ ]
yeah see you were coming at it from
something that's coming from from an
angle where i knew
more about it you know jenny's big into
this witches and witchcraft stuff so
maybe she's
more but she pays closer attention than
i do
yeah certain things and i think she's a
little more wired for
things that are more slow paced and more
intricate i'm not really
uh wired that way um i like
fast-paced big splashy stories
theatrical
[ __ ] um the dialogue's [ __ ] real
clear-cut
it's it's trying to give you a very
easy to understand message and it's
playing with you that way
visually and or to you know
it's more visually stimulating and stuff
if not i'm just gonna
get kind of relaxed and
zone out my mind's gonna start wandering
around i'll probably fall asleep you
know
i did i fell asleep on this one in the
theater um
i stayed awake the second time
it did get better um
more stuff started to happen that kind
of kept me interested but like she said
half of it i didn't even know i'd even
know that it happened i needed her to
tell me that it happened
i didn't know yeah because there's a lot
of connections between everything that
happens in there
if you're not like i said there's
nothing nothing in there is wasted
everything that's in there connects to
something else right
uh thank you no need for me too we made
it in time to drop a super chat ended up
showing late last few streams that's
okay thank you very much bro
uh yeah he also said o.g wickerman with
christopher lee was so good i know i
love that movie
um though i like the nicolas cage one i
still can't se i've i've watched like
scenes from it i'm just like i don't
know i'll have to be in the booth i saw
it i saw the nicholas yeah
i liked it it was it was [ __ ] a [ __ ]
show
it was a [ __ ] show but that didn't mean
i didn't like it i liked it
well i i've liked plenty of movies that
are [ __ ] shows is it an entertaining
[ __ ]
yes then all right yes it looks
entertaining
actually we ought to see it again we
should sit
we'll we'll get some drinks and uh and
watch it one night it'll probably be
hilarious
it's very different from the first one
uh yeah that's so i've heard
it it's it's a lot more fast paced it's
dumber
more exciting it was really kind of like
something more i would like
yeah it is because it's dumber yeah
dumber more exciting and [ __ ]
nicholas cage cages the [ __ ] out through
it all the time no not the bees not the
bees
they put his [ __ ] head in the damn b
bucket and [ __ ] look at this [ __ ]
funny
it's it's more like midsummer but
midsummer has actually done a lot better
well yeah that's everybody i don't think
anyone's gonna argue with you on that
score
that is real crazy phil asks who like
the omen i do i do i love i love you
i've seen it a million times uh actually
the whole series is good
yeah actually i i quite like all of them
uh
final conflict is great thorn cezanne
says not really scary but artsy is
hexan actually that's a silent movie and
actually yeah i did a um
a really long blog post on that like
several years ago when i was going on
like a big silent movie kick
and um that movie has some like kind of
disturbing imagery in it for as [ __ ]
old as it is when it comes out 1921
something like that um but yeah it's got
it's almost kind of like a weird like
quasi documentary about witchcraft
but then kind of a movie too it's very
strange
i kind of dug it though it's like and a
lot of the imagery and it was like creep
and i've seen imagery from that movie
like turn up in music videos and [ __ ]
like that without anybody like saying
where it came from cause i'm like hey
that's axan
you know what i mean but this is a good
movie um
knowing what the movie and story is
about helps i think
oh it helps with dumbasses like myself i
needed heard so what is going on
who's this woman yeah that kind of [ __ ]
there's a cult there's a cult
really you know okay yes because it's
not real
clearly spelled out to somebody like me
i guess
i just i kind of come from a different
traditions
of storytelling traditions i guess to me
like i said for a general audience
horror for a general audience that would
be poltergeist
there is no there is no there are no
shades of gray in poltergeist
but that's also but i also love that
yeah i like that too but it's like a
commercial
yeah i mean a child could follow that i
like
all kinds of hormones yeah you know what
i mean not like i'm not super picky
this is more along the lines of
something like
the shining but it's even more difficult
it's more cerebral it's a cerebral
horror film
which i like though because if you saw
the shining you can read the
the stephen king book and see what what
it is
kubrick is talking about you you know
that there's ghosts on the other side
that are doing all this
uh the story makes a lot more sense if
you understood what the spirit
what was going on in the spirit world
from the book
but kubrick did it the right way that
wouldn't make a good movie
he just did it for the viewpoint of what
would um
the wife what was her name [ __ ] wendy
yeah what would windy
how would wendy experience all this
because she didn't see any of the ghosts
until the very end she didn't know what
was going on
yeah you know so that's what this
that's what that book would have been
like from wendy's point of view i think
that was kubrick's
that was the best way to do it best
decision was one to take out all the
exposition
yeah that was in the book right which
i'm not [ __ ] on it because i love
that book oh it's a great book
but for a movie that's for a movie you
don't want exposition
and and turning the uh hedge animals
into a maze
yeah two best decisions he made yeah
well they didn't have the technology to
do the hedge animals back then
and when they did the hedge animals in
stephen king's mini series version it
looked
stupid yeah i mean it's going to be
really hard to make that not look stupid
in the book it was creepy
because you were imagining it but when
you saw a move in the book
yeah well that's another it was only
when your back was turned did they move
which that yeah and that's creepy yeah
but when they show it in a movie not so
much
he saw a move at the very very end when
they got up on the house and the house
was getting ready to blow up he said it
looked like they were moving
like a flicker book yeah and um and it
was in the night
in the darkness it was pretty cool but
um
yeah that's that's exactly how you do it
the the only difference though
kubrick said this is a horror movie
somebody's got to have to die
so they had to kill halloran yeah and in
the book he survived
yeah yeah but like i said i like tyler
and as a character but i
i respect kubrick's decision to kill him
because like i said
i really liked it made it scarier
because it's like all
he you've been following halloran
through this whole [ __ ] [ __ ] and it's
like you know
i gotta go get him and it's like he had
the shining and he had the message and
he like
goes through hell in high water to get
up there and then he gets killed
immediately
and i was just kind of like that is that
just
um it just made the power of the hotel
like that much scarier because it's like
look and
look at all the [ __ ] this dude went
through and it was for nothing no well
it wasn't for nothing because he saved
him
he did save him because he got the snow
cap there and they left in that so it's
like it wasn't
you know nothing it wasn't for nothing
but yeah but i didn't give his life to
save him
i did like i did like that but uh yeah
so thorn cezanne says i
uh i love cerebral horror gore bores me
after a while yeah it's like there's
like this
yeah there's only so much i mean i like
gore i'm i'm a
gore person it depends on what mood i'm
in really i don't really
you know there's certain genres of
horror that i like more than others
but if a lot of people recommend a
horror movie to me i'll give it a go
it doesn't really matter what kind it is
even it's like found footage or
something because i know a lot of
people's like oh i don't like found
footage but then i can think of like at
least 10 movies right now that were
found footage that i really liked so
this this one is very complicated if i
were to watch it a couple more times and
probably get
understand all the angles i'd probably
get an appreciation
for it but it's not a fun watch not from
my point of view
well jenny it was but not for me well no
it wasn't a fun watch but that's why i
liked it because i was like it's a
horror movie
i was like so and like i said it it's
definitely not
an enjoyable yeah horror movie to watch
i mean some
and some horror movies are like if it's
just like a fun slasher or whatever
this one is a lot more heavy
like the joker of horror movies that's
actually probably a good way of putting
it
it's going to kind of make you feel
crappy after your work joker's
the joker is a masterpiece but it's not
that fun to watch
yeah you got to really be in the right
mood for it that's what i'm saying
but but like i said since it's a horror
movie um
the fact that it made me feel bad was
good
you know what i mean because it's like
that's kind of what i wanted a horror
movie to do
and one hadn't done that for me in a
long time so
as much as it pissed me off because i
was like man i really didn't want to
feel like this today
like after i saw it uh because it was
really
unpleasant it was an unpleasant
experience but on the other hand
i was also kind of like [ __ ] awesome
man i haven't had a [ __ ] horror movie
do that in like forever like give me
nightmares and [ __ ] off
i gotta truthfully say though that i
didn't really have any much reaction to
it
well i know yeah yeah not midsummer i
did but not not this i
i didn't have a connection with any of
the characters i guess
uh you know what i mean like you see
characters get killed and you don't
really care about you don't like them
then it doesn't really matter
in mid-summer you kind of you could kind
of sympathize with the people that were
being killed or
under you i could understand what the
hell was going on i was as weirded out
as they were
type of deal yeah he was putting you in
the same city yeah right so i could kind
of understand
but there was just something about the
the characters in this movie i didn't
really
didn't really care about him i didn't
like the little girl i didn't like the
the
the dude i didn't like the mom or the
dad
well another thing too is that the one
of the points of the movie and like i
said
the reason it called hereditary they're
not just talking about the curse like
the cult
that's you know generational but they're
also talking about
um like a cycle of abuse because the mom
was like either
i don't know if she was necessarily
physically abusive but she was for sure
like emotionally abusive
and then like the mom was like repeating
the cycle without wanting to
so it was kind of like multi-layered
yeah you know what i'm saying
and um so the fact that the family was
so
fragmented and didn't communicate with
one another and were
all like that was what made them
vulnerable
to the demon yeah i guess so because
they didn't communicate with one another
the way a family should they were broken
apart
yeah so that was kind of like the point
of them all being like that was that
that was what made them a target that
was what made the cult
able to infiltrate uh and do what they
wanted to do because they didn't because
these families were just they were off
doing their own thing and they there was
so much
uh hostility and like resentment and
stuff between all of the characters
because of all the [ __ ] that had gone on
in the past
so i think what i don't know where this
is taking place but
um you know having lived and worked in
massachusetts
in the wellesley western and dover area
i dealt with a lot of
upper class white families new english
families and and this family reminded me
of that
and i never really liked them they all
kind of have a certain
quality sometimes too it's like i don't
necessarily and i've said this on some
of my like book reviews yeah
because sometimes you read a book and
you don't like the characters
but they're still but i don't think you
necessarily have to like the characters
if the characters are interesting i
don't have to like them it doesn't
really matter to you
it's like if it's a good story yeah um
the dude abide says it's like we need to
talk about kevin yeah that's kind it's
kind of like a similar
uh situation to that where it's like i
don't really think
and i've you know some of like um like
one of the books that i reviewed like
sharp objects by um what's her name uh
gillian flynn
it's like i didn't particularly like
that character but she was
interesting enough and relatable enough
that i wanted to know what was gonna
happen you know what i mean like
everybody in that was kind of like a
piece of [ __ ]
yeah but that it it didn't bother me so
i don't necessarily have to like the
characters to be into the story yeah me
i didn't
a lot of times when i was working i was
dealing with families you know what i
mean that
had they've been wealthy for generations
but they're totally dysfunctional
and they this fam this kind of family
reminded me of them
you know what i mean and they're
dysfunctional but they look down their
noses at you
because you're not one of them you know
what i'm in freaking and they all went
to the right schools and [ __ ]
and and it's just there's just to me
they were they were always kind of like
a turn off
you know so that this family kind of
struck me as
people like that so i just didn't really
care you know
i just that's just personal though i
don't think other people would have that
um uh experience it's just
that's that was my interpretation where
was this taking place
well they shot it in utah but i don't
think they wasn't supposed to be utah no
i don't think they really said
i don't think it mattered i think it was
supposed to be new england
maybe but like i said they shot it in
utah so i don't know
probably massachusetts or probably
massachusetts is probably
supposed to be maybe it's hard it's hard
to say
another thing i didn't quite pick up on
the first time but i picked up more the
second time was that
the dad used to be annie's
psychiatrist and then they got married
later on like after they weren't seeing
each other anymore and i was like well
that's a pretty [ __ ] up dynamic too
because he acted like a lot more like a
therapist than a husband
and that's why because i didn't pick
that up exactly the first time
because he's like writing an email to
one of his colleagues like later like
hey i think my wife's losing her [ __ ]
you might want to like look into that
but yeah so that was another thing
there's a this is one that you can watch
over and over and there's like all these
little details
and you pick up like more [ __ ] every
single time just like the shining like i
said which i've probably seen a hundred
times but every time i watch it
there's like new [ __ ] that turns up you
know what i'm saying
um somebody said something about saw
dude said i'm a small it from a small
town in scotland america scares the [ __ ]
out of me dude america scares the [ __ ]
out of me man
i'm from here well it depends where you
go
america is a big country there's like
most of most of it is not scary
there's 50 states here man each one of
these states is the size of a european
country
people forget that i think texas is
twice the size of germany
um so and really the only thing that
they have in common is that they watch
the same television as you see look at
the same movies but other than that
there's
it's more regions you know what i mean a
lot of your southern states
in the southern regions are similar uh
new england states are kind of similar
there'll be differences in the cities
but the general culture is the same the
midwest is all kind of the same
um california well there's difference in
north and south california you know
northern and southern california there's
differences but california is like its
own country
you know same as texas well
texas is a part of the south but it's
like its own country
it's like a different it's like a
mixture of the south and mexico
yeah it's you know and it was that and
that's what it was it was a
joint venture between a real rich
american family and a real rich
mexican family it was a it was having to
do with the cattle business
that was when texas was first formed
long time ago
so each little state is like it's in
its own little world you know you never
know what you're gonna find here
yeah it's always uh it's always a
surprise yeah
i mean you can go to places out here in
florida not far just
an hour or so from here these little
nooks and crannies and houses out in the
middle of the damn wilderness
it's like and we were going to see her
mom and we ended up in one of those
places and i'm like
no roads it's just dirt roads doing this
car almost getting stuck and there's
houses you're in middle school and
that's only like an hour from there
like an hour away and jenny's like get
us out of here
man i hear banjos
and i'm from mississippi and that place
kind of [ __ ] heavy a little bit
they're harmless people it's just that
you never know what they think of you
and there's no cell phone service no no
that's a little uh yeah and that's their
land
not yours if you understand what i'm
talking about yeah yeah that's that's
their place
yeah they're like what are you doing
here yeah city folk yeah
it's like some [ __ ] out of star wars you
know walking and
walking to the [ __ ] motorcycle
[ __ ] spaceport
you never know what you know
the locals have their own ways of doing
things which probably just like kill you
and bury you behind their
trailer that's something that i've heard
that evidently the chinese [ __ ] are
terrified of getting outside of a city
because
it's not it's not a police state you
know what i mean here in the united
states so they so you could
they're like moy you could disappear in
america somebody could kill you and no
one would ever know and that that is
it happens all the time it happens all
the time and that keeps a lot of people
in cities
well i can't say i blame them because
like i said i've been out to just some
places out here and i'm just kind of
like man like somebody could murder me
out here
like i don't like going out there by
myself you don't know like you don't
know what [ __ ] crazy people are
running around out there yeah well
having grown up half the time in down
mississippi i was always care i was
always packing anyway
you know this concept of calling the
police to come help you
it doesn't really exist in most of the
united states people have to kind of
take care of themselves it's still kind
of a
frontier type situation even in these
little small villages and towns
like heidelberg mississippi you know
half them people [ __ ] carrying guns
because there's there's two policemen
for that town one in a day and one in
the night
you know and they're like you know
they're there to clean up the mess
and it's not violent it's very peaceful
the the uh
the crime rate is very low and it's
because everybody's watching their own
back
and and it's the population density is
very
very sparse you know yeah i mean i think
we don't have that many people and they
all kind of know each other they all
kind of know each other
and uh they're all kind of looking out
for each other they're not hostile
but they don't like outsiders until they
get to know you
you know if you give them a good story
why you're there and oh okay then it's
okay
but they're they're they don't want
people coming into their [ __ ] [ __ ]
their [ __ ] up
a couple people asked about skinwalker
ranch we did a show about skinwalker
ranch didn't we
i'm pretty sure we did a show about
skinwalker ranch it was probably a while
back but i'm pretty sure we did one
yeah you know um all right so
are are we done are you yeah [ __ ]
louis says i'd rather
walk in downtown south central than at
night than in some of the rural areas
any time
well it depends louie there i probably
would too there are places in
mississippi where you could just [ __ ]
walk and just not see anybody
for a long long time nobody bother you
but there it will it only takes one
person to bother you doesn't it
like i said before okay mississippi is a
great example it's the most
armed state in the united states it's
also the poorest
all right it um it it
has the largest black population but it
has the lowest crime rate
and it has the highest incident the
highest gun ownership but it has the
lowest crime rate and it's because the
population density is so low
people aren't stressed out they're poor
but but the dollar buys a lot i mean
for 350 bucks a month in certain areas
you can damn near get an old victorian
mansion for that
and some of these are you couldn't air
condition it but you know
you could get a big old house for 400
bucks a month
in mississippi and just see if you can
make 400 bucks a month it depends you
know but
with the advent of the internet that's
possible oh yeah
but it was harder back then because you
were dependent on local jobs
and not anymore yeah so
you could be a stock broker downtown new
york
and if you're working over a laptop
making
hundreds of thousands of dollars a year
you could move to mississippi and be the
rich one of the richest people in the
state
literally you could be living in a giant
mansion
the only thing close to that would be
mexico mexico if like a dollar goes a
long way in mexico
again khan was showing me what
what 1500 a month buys in mexico a
[ __ ] palace
yeah twice as nice as this house phil
says i found out that at state parks uh
every year at least 6 000 people
disappear and they do not keep track of
them
yeah that would not surprise me yeah but
they're not dying from murder well no
not necessarily they're probably just
like
they're getting lost yeah they're
getting lost and they die of uh
exposure and uh if you die even
even if you were to die in the woods
even just a mile from where we live
right now the chances of them finding
your body would be slim
because at night the animals would come
and tear you apart and they'd all run in
different directions with you
and they're talking about 70s serial
killers honestly
70s and 80s were kind of like the heyday
yeah that was the worst if you want to
say
yeah i think the as far as that goes if
i remember this correctly i could be
totally wrong
but i think the um the peak of serial
killings was 87
that was the year that had the most and
then after that it started declining
um so yeah the 70s like i said might
have been all that lead poisoning might
have been like cultural [ __ ] might have
been just it was probably like a perfect
storm of [ __ ] that all kind of came to a
head
during the 1970s because that was kind
of the [ __ ] worst
as far as serial killers 70s and 80s um
it's gotten better since then so it's
probably like considerably safer
at least as far as like serial killers
are concerned yeah which you know
and serial killing was always like a
suburban and urban thing
that's not all that rural it happened in
rural areas it does
it's just not as likely
you got to have a certain amount of
population density yeah that's where the
victims are
well yeah that means generally they're
going to go like where there's a victim
pool
right you know to some degree yeah all
right so
are you ready to wrap it up yeah let me
wrap it up all right so
uh it's tuesday so that means tomorrow
night is our sidetrack show
at 5 p.m 5 p.m so yeah we'll be drinking
and talking about [ __ ] on there
might talk about who knows what we're
going to talk about might talk about
some more horror movies might talk about
some other stuff
man i got to start watching i'm doing a
um i'm recording a show in a couple
weeks
and we're going to be talking about uh
the handmaid's tale
so i really need to get on watching that
because i haven't started watching it
yet like i
get i keep meaning to like watch it but
i just haven't had time
because i really want to watch it i read
the book a long time ago did you get
that super chat
uh where was it from i don't know i
think you were you were probably talking
yeah
uh no need for me to yeah thank thank
you very much uh love the star wars
reference can't stand the disney star
wars yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i don't like i said i'm not i'm
ambivalent about the tissue star wars i
know people get really really uh
butthurt about it but i don't really
care one way or the other
so uh yeah uh dude about says ace great
show peoples will definitely subscribe
and watch more well thank you very much
uh we talk about a lot of creepy [ __ ]
true crime horror movies
i love all that kind of stuff so
we will see you guys uh tomorrow evening
at 5 p.m
we'll have a drink we'll talk about
whatever like we usually do on
wednesdays tom might put some wigs on
it'll be super fun i might put wigs on i
don't know maybe not we'll see how it
goes
we never know what's going to happen
it's going to be a big surprise all
right so uh thanks everybody for
dropping by and thanks for the super
chats
and we'll see you guys tomorrow bye